[Music]
it's hard to give a definition because
political ideologies turn into tribes
and so people affiliate
with those in the group they like to
interact with that they value morally
and nowadays especially in the united
states it's harder and harder to discern
a common intellectual thread behind the
left and the right
we see that especially in the right
where you have
uh pro-russian anti-free trade
right-wingers boggling the mind of
anyone who
uh was a right-winger even ten years ago
uh
also though the uh left has switched to
a number of its affiliations
but i would use it informally in the way
that
uh people tend to identify
those who are sympathetic with with uh
socialism
those who tend to be uh at least in
american politics more
likely to be the democratic party than
the republican party
there are a number of positions that go
with it but they can often be
blurred as the coalitions themselves
recoales
would you identify with or do you
identify with someone who's on the left
um no uh i certainly don't identify
with with uh the right and most people
would identify me based on my positions
as a center left in terms of i believe
in a
graduated income tax i believe in
regulations on
uh uh environmental uh disfoliation
uh i uh i i agree
i'm in favor of um uh social programs
like
welfare and medicine on the other hand i
also believe
in uh the importance of markets i
believe in
the privacy of free speech and
individual rights
uh i believe that uh policing is an
important
component of uh reduction of violence
which is not a popular view
on the left so i have an eclectic uh mix
which i examine on an issue by issue
basis and evaluate in terms of my best
reading of the evidence
i try not to fall into an ideology on
the right or the left
you